what's up guys lunch money coming to you
on what's today Wednesday Wednesday
well wall shoots rich while Wall Street
is trying to get rich the rest of us is
trying to get our lunch money right
maybe I'll learn how to speak here
shortly I have missed playing tamara
nova who thankfully doesn't look like
she's in prison doesn't look like she's
trying to dress up like me for Halloween
she is ready to go in her nice what is
this like art shirt was it's not an art
it kind of looks like a bird sure it
looks like you just painted it on there
before today
alright see I'm gonna give you a hard
time today what's the first time more
relief Senate passes four hundred and
eighty four billion dollar coronavirus
bill for small businesses and hospital
relief and also testing do we not
already get a bill for small businesses
this is one of many bills that have been
passed so technically this hasn't been
passionate just the Senate pass it now
has to go to Congress they've got to get
it done as well it only gets signed by
the president but what's really
important here is 310 of the four
hundred eighty four billion dollars is
for the payroll protection program which
is for small businesses there's a whole
bunch of controversy that's been going
on with this who's been getting and how
much have they gotten usually give it
back
etc but they ran out of money right but
is there a risk that those companies
that shouldn't have gotten who will get
this batch to bless when they're trying
to figure out now rather trying to work
through the application process and so
this 310 billion dollars is gonna go on
top of the three hundred and fifty
billion dollars they already have given
out but what's important to remember is
more than one trillion dollars of loan
applications have been put in so three
hundred fifty billion dollars only
funded about three percent alone
applications so let's say that they give
the 310 billion to gets approved and
then all of a sudden they go and they
start to hand out the loans what are
they gonna get to six percent seven ten
percent of all the loan applications
there's got to do another bill after
that and so what ends up happening is
every time they got to go back and do a
bill you gotta go through this process
there's a week that come transpires and
so I bet this bill doesn't get passed if
it gets passed till the end of the week
and at the end of the week happens that
means one whole week went by where no
one was getting money businesses were
shutting down and people were getting
laid off that's crazy
not good then the other money though is
in there out of the three out of the
four 94 billion so 3:10 does a small
business's payroll protection program
but the remainder of the capital is for
hospitals and for testing the hospitals
is a huge piece of a lot of people don't
understand so if you think of a hospital
as of business they basically have two
separate types of business they've got
like the ER which means you can walk in
and you can get something done right
there on the spot and then they've got
an entire other part of their business
around elective surgeries you know
primary care and all the other things
that can happen because everything's
been shut down
dentists are shut down elective
surgeries are shut down all of these
things the revenue in a hospital is
actually very much high revenue low
volume is where they make all the money
right because it are a high margin thing
so when you get a surgery when you go to
a dental the dentist that's all high
margins stuff the ER is not very high
margin for them and in some cases
actually they either break even or it's
a loss later they actually lose money to
get you in diagnosan and send you out to
some of the high margin stuff so right
now all of the high margin revenue at a
hospital just disappeared because
they're not doing anything other than
treating this and so these hospitals are
gonna come under immense financial
pressure and so the government's gonna
basically bail them out with with some
relief funding I mean I I say give all
the money to the hospitals small
businesses yeah but like they're not
even getting it anyway well there are
definitely situations like Harvard or
Shake Shack right I think in the first
tranche seventy five publicly traded
companies received money from the did
some of them give the money back or was
that only Shake Shack I'm not sure how
many of them gave it back I know for
sure che checked it I'm sure more of
them will be pressured to do it and look
part of this is not that they did
something illegal but I think that's a
really important piece of this the rules
state if you have less than as many
employees if you do whatever and then
you can apply for this right and so
that's what they're doing is they're
following the rules
but when you zoom out something like
Shake Shack and I don't know if this is
exactly what they did but let's just say
they look at each location we say well
that's a franchise franchise has less
than 500 employees therefore they can
get money right well yes but Shake Shack
so 1.6 billion dollar company right and
so what's gonna end up happening here
they're gonna get this stuff sorted out
but we got to get money in the hands of
the people that need it because remember
I'm actually against doing most of this
stuff right I actually don't think that
we should the government should be
saving people and should be bailing
people out etc but if you're going to do
it you got to really do it you got to
get money into people's hands right get
the lunch money I what's going on with
the data breach so the Small Business
Association administration
administration as well Business
Administration website leaked the
personal data of 8,000 small business
loan applicants so that's not good what
do you think about this well I mean it's
just not a secure site apparently well
we don't have all the information right
and I think part of this is there's a
specific portals economic injury
disaster loan portal which is leaked
what leak could have two things either
could be somebody hacked the site right
and literally stole the information or
there could be somebody who I have your
password right and I got in that way so
it's unclear exactly what happened here
but definitely there's a lot of PPI
personal no PII personally identifiable
information PII that got leaked and also
all of the business information so think
about being a small business right now
you're reeling you need financial help
you apply for a loan then BAM somebody
just stole your information and next
thing you know a credit card gets opened
in your name or something like that it's
really really bad but if you were one of
those people who applied affected
applicants will receive a year of free
credit monitoring is that this I kinda
do you think that's that's worth getting
hacked no it's pretty crazy right yeah
and some of the information that was
leaked included Social Security numbers
tax ID numbers household size and phone
numbers I mean the Social Security
numbers pretty pretty bad if you were a
hacker and you got somebody's phone
number would you call them up no why
would I do that that's a cycle
I got you I got your information no I
was going on with Harvard please don't
have maybe the hacker needs a friend
they just want to talk to somebody all
right so you feel very passionately
about this so why don't you tell us
what's going on
with Harvard Harvard took nine million
dollars from the US government for
financial aid any point six whatever
nice I like the fact checking here and
important to know they did not take it
out of the payroll protection program
this was a separate part of the bill
where the US government gave schools or
colleges billions of dollars and Harvard
received nine million dollars out of
this Harvard though has a forty one or a
forty billion dollar endowment and the
reason why I feel so passionately about
this is you have a school the school
does great things it educates people
that do research they do all these nice
they employ people right all these
things that happen at the school and
then you have an endowment and the
endowment is basically either money from
the school or donations from alumni and
they use that kind of core capital or
that principle to grow over time and as
they grow that money they then are
supposed to be supporting the school but
there's a couple of nuances that make
all of this a sham in my opinion the
first is sham endowments pay little to
no tax so almost all of the money grows
tax-free right which okay sounds fine
but in Harvard's case for example the
endowment only supports 35 percent of
Harvard's budget on a yearly basis they
just keep growing it right and so what
ends up happening is they take 35% of
Harvard's budget in the endowment pays
for it but where does the rest of the
money come from
they asked alumni for donations they
asked students to take on hundreds of
thousands of dollars of student debt to
pay for or they ask the taxpayers
through federal funding to give them
money so they can operate their school
again I'm fine with that if you want to
run your business however you want
that's okay but if you take taxpayers
money you should have to pay the full
tax rate you should not get the tax
break
on your endowment so while we're funding
your school so I've read a bunch of
stuff about the criticism etc do we know
what Harvard's position on this is do
they have a compelling reason as to why
they took that you put six million well
the government specifically carved it
out and said we're gonna give us the
school so it's not like they it's not
like they went and they said they
applied for anything so ladies Trump
well so the government definitely and I
think the way that the amount of money
each one got was determined by how much
federal funding they were seen right so
it's kind of like on a pro-rata basis so
it's not like Harvard went in and said
hey eight point six million you know
whatever the problem is now there's a
bunch of backlash they're saying wait a
second why our tax payers giving you
even more money when you have a forty
billion dollar endowment it doesn't
sound like that's Harvard's problem
that's something the government well
Harvard could also say we're gonna be
upstanding citizens to our country and
we're not gonna take millions of dollars
because we have enough money right so
maybe don't give it back but who's to
say well that's what everyone's freaking
out about now and and here's the bigger
piece of this in my opinion is it's not
just are they taking the money are they
not taking the money right Harvard has
enough money in their endowment to pay
for every student to go to that school
for free for 20-plus years right and so
again you can run your business however
you want my whole thing is just pay your
taxes they're an asset management from
the endowment is an asset management
firm they employ investment
professionals they manage billions of
dollars right all stuff every other
asset management firm in the world's got
to pay a certain tax rate Harvard
doesn't have to do that because they're
supposed to use school but you even pay
50% of the budget of the school so it's
like being a minority shareholder in a
business right or you do you really own
the business or do you just have equity
in a bit but you don't mean like you
don't even provide 50% of funding for
the school so you don't provide 50% why
do you get the tax breaks
it's very nuanced situation I actually
think that was gonna happen here the
schools would give back the money
because there's too much public pressure
and then on top of that there's probably
gonna be a lot of questions one fun fact
for you from 2010 to 2015 the Ivy League
schools received over forty billion
dollars of federal funding on average
annually that's about four point eight
billion per school I believe right I
need to do more research
on this cuz I don't understand why the
private schools are getting federal
funding the state school it's all of the
programs that they get so it could be
Federal Pell Pell grants like all these
things got traced back and so there is
this it's called open the books calm
which is a federally funded part of the
government's budget all about
transparency of government spending and
when they trace this all back what they
found was the Ivy League schools each
school receives on average more federal
funding than 16 different states in the
United States
so there's actually more federal funding
going to an Ivy League school than some
states which is just a old development
so fun fact I went to a public school in
you into a private school did you
receive any federal aid I have I
actually don't remember exactly how I
got paid for because I also had the army
oh yeah it's when you joined you join
with the ROTC no wait how did it work I
was already in the army when I joined
and I played football so there's a whole
bunch of thing actually don't remember
the exact breakdown of like where all of
the money came from but they definitely
made it possible so that I have to go
into debt but I also traded my body my
time serves the country etc right and so
part of that is like I actually know the
belief like the number one problem has
to be solved in America or one of the
biggest problems is student debt but
we've kids who are graduating with
hundreds of thousands of dollars of debt
it's just hard to operate and to go
build a you know a strong foundation
financially if you've got that yeah all
right what's next upholstery boat way
chipotle agrees to pay twenty five
million dollar penalty for that 2015 to
2018 norovirus outbreak norovirus not to
be confused with corona virus this one
has to do with like vomiting and
diarrhea and what the page basically
people who went to Chipotle got sick do
you remember 2015 there was this big
like I remember there were lines out the
door for Chipotle one day and then the
next day the news was like norovirus I
thought it was no no lines but there was
e.coli at one point I think well it was
that a difference well no I think
that that's part of it I'm not a
scientist I don't know about all the
viruses I just thought that a virus was
I thought they were all it's just one
virus and now else now you learn there's
like multiple corona viruses but we're
immune to some where we have all sorts
of things like the common flu some of
the strains are called corona virus as
well but it's a different version it
gets wild at 22 we need to do our
research but basically they had a bunch
of people I think it was a thousand
people got sick comment 25 million
dollars yeah well this is the largest
fine ever imposed on a food safety case
yeah more than 1,100 people fell ill
from the outbreaks did anybody die I
don't think so maybe supers got sick so
it's probably more of hey here's a
penalty and you should why did it take
this long
well it's why I got to go through an
investigation all I can say but also
it's a penalty not only to punish them
but also to like send a message to
everybody else I take this stuff
seriously handling all that did you do
you remember after that hit did you go
back to Chipotle I don't think I ever
stopped going to Chipotle I don't think
even knew about that well if you
experienced any severe vomiting or
diarrhea during that period of time this
is why diarrhea is weird man okay don't
worry what's going on Netflix your you
know rose him in the comments that's
what you do to me okay Netflix Netflix
Netflix please don't have another laugh
attack we don't need that right now
Netflix had its earnings report and they
they said they had 16 million new
subscribers in the first quarter I
believe which was blew past their
projection of 7 million
how many cool oh so they increased 23%
that's a big number
yeah but the the CEO was very kind of
measured and he was like this is a
terrible crisis you know this is only
temporary don't expect this sort of
growth in the future
do you I mean how much of this do you
think was Tiger King actually not
at nearly as much as you would think
everyone thinks that Tiger King was so
popular Tiger King wasn't even the most
watched show on Netflix in the month of
March
what is the watch the trash : nope tell
me tell me what it is blind love love
his bluff is lying yeah a new spot for
all the guys out there actually pretty
good is pretty funny
would you like about it I was like that
they're sitting in the with a pod right
they're sitting in a room and they got
to talk to each other through a wall I
was like man that's awesome that's kind
of how we met I mean like I didn't see
he we met he went to a Koosh I was in a
room by myself locked in there with no
windows we went to India you came back
and we just like talked on the phone for
like a month
yeah I thought I was talking to a robot
that's such a lovely voice like okay all
right so the number one show on Netflix
though was Spencer confidential New York
the new Mark Wahlberg yeah hope you want
to watch it but yeah so basically they
definitely had these viral hits tired
king you know cuz actually technically
you know you can save on that one do you
know you could say but right I mean like
Netflix at this point has to be
replacing television for most people dad
and tick tock tick tock you think really
do you remember this morning I was
watching tick tock yeah but they're not
very interesting when I got sucked in
it's just a war of attention Rick rich
greenfield told me he's like a big
analyst on Wall Street for media and
technology and he said to me most people
look at it as like streaming Wars so
Spotify Burres Apple music whatever and
look at like Hoover's Netflix and the
Millican television cable provider
suppose so he goes the problem that
everyone is missing is it's just a war
on attention
yeah right it's who can get if you look
at 24 hours in a day you're gonna sleep
let's call six to eight of them then the
remainder of your day everyone's
competing for every second of that time
and so actually Instagram is competitive
with Netflix which is competitive with
music which is competitive with
television which is competitive with
book publishers right and they're all
competing for how much of your time can
I get
and then you can also look at your phone
and get your screen time and things like
that
I do you think it's very generational
though right like your parents my
parents they will forever kind of be
like their attention goes to the TV they
doesn't as much as Netflix grows and I
don't know I think for us it'll be big
but my parents put on television as like
its background right yeah they just turn
it on and just play it yeah dude what
would what TV station your voice
I need earplugs okay last one what else
we got so okay so there's the
six-year-old Russian girl she six she is
you said girl like you had a question
about this child well six years old is
your child and can be a girl's message
these tubes most popular child star
guess how many oh no I already told you
well you guys can't guess cuz you I
can't you can't tell me oh you're strong
she has 53 million YouTube subscribers
how many do you have
we have not that many I mean it's
basically your channel your show at this
point fifty-three millions a lot and
also her video some of the videos have
over 100 million beautiful servers we
watched one of her videos it's really
well done it
and you can watch it and like she's
speaking Russian she's speaking Russian
but you could still tell what's going on
through the animations and all that
stuff so it's pretty good I what is the
name of the thing you gotta tell people
this it's well it's called Nastya
sty I think that's short for her name
Anastasia well as an American who
doesn't understand Russian it's spelled
nasty eh okay anything else any last
minutes 4 seconds anything words for the
people for the people
yeah I mean just be kind you're really
on the beat kind the train there all
right guys listen we appreciate you
watching lunch money every day
noon ish sometime around noon if we get
our [ __ ] together we'll Wall Street
trying to get rich the rest so it's just
trying to get our lunch money right
today yeah of course I'm a at
chick-fil-a yesterday this big win big
win yesterday with the chick-fil-a this
morning I take his lunch money Bliley
we got bully no I was kind of I was kind
to my friend we'll see you guys tomorrow